[Musique]
il
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui je
reçois une jeune et talentueuse
écrivaine yvelinoise elle s'appelle
mélissa da costa mélissa bonjour ou jour
r6 nous rejoindre sur le plateau de tv
78 pour ce vide que l'on va entièrement
vous consacrez vous allez bien très bien
et vous mais moi ça va être super sur
avis tout voir vous avez une histoire de
vie mr de carrière qui donne pleins
d'espoir une belle histoire voilà
j'avais envie qu'on la raconte j'avais
envie qu'on parle de vos livres aussi
bien sûr qu'ils sont des des succès et
c'est juste génial alors mélissa moi
j'aimerais bien connaitre votre arrivée
à la publication vous en êtes donc comme
je disais tout à l'heure à votre
quatrième roman il vient de sortir il
s'appelle les douleurs fantômes donc le
voici
comment s'est passé votre votre arrivée
à l'écriture dite moi peut vous êtes
vous avez grandi ou déjà alors j'ai
grandi dans l'ain dans un petit village
pas très loin de mâcon avait un point
rural vivant et l'écriture en fait elle
a toujours fait partie de moi j'ai pas
spécialement de souvenir de moi sans
écriture à 7 ans à partir du moment où
j'ai été capable de former des mots
former des phrases c'est devenu un jeu
comme on joue à cache cache comme on
joue au papa et la maman vraiment
l'écriture c'était un jeu c'était
quelque chose de ludique et je me suis
mis à y passer de plus en plus de temps
ça m'a jamais vraiment quitté donc le
tout au long de ma scolarité un collège
lycée j'avais toujours ce truc d'écrire
dans des cahiers d'école parfois
j'écrivais avec des amis on écrivait des
romans à que adhérents six mois oui
c'est ça c'était pas uniquement celui
perd finalement non non j'ai beaucoup
écrit avec mon cousin on n'était pas
dedans du fantastique des amis de deux
collèges et lycées c'était plutôt des
histoires d'ados de films et c'est
toujours resté dans sa magic lui disiez
pour écrire plusieurs comme ça à chacune
su partager
ses neiges en fait
exactement et deviens et et chacune
avait sa voix un moment du récit pour
parler en étant un personnage parfait je
comprends et alors après vous avez donc
commencé des études littéraires
j'imagine un pas du tout
alors je me destinais pas forcément à
des études littéraires pour moi
l'écriture c'était c'était une passion
et c'est tout un métier par métier en
tout cas je me voyais pas partir dans de
l'étude de lettres classiques des choses
comme ça ce qui vraiment ne faisait
vibrer c'était vraiment ce qui avait
trait à la psychologie pendant des
années j'ai voulu devenir psychologue
d'accra et puis je me suis un petit peu
laissée influencer on disait que les fac
de psycho été bouchés et c'est un métier
très compliqué à pouvoir exercer donc je
me suis montrée plus raisonnable je suis
parti en économie gestion tout en
gardant cet attrait pour les choses
humaines les schémas relationnels les
blessures la résilience c'est toujours
rester là et vous avez continué à écrire
aussi pendant pause étude tout le temps
d'accord imminent alors il ya eu des
phases peut-être d'un an un an et demi
où je touchais plus à mes amis roman et
pizarro revenait tout le temps qu un
autre sarkozy retourniez vous aviez
toujours un roman en train oui en cours
qui attendaient d'être terminée oui oui
toujours ou dans la tête ont tous fait
des histoires s'écrivent est dans la
tête d'accor et puis
est alors suspect alors pendant
longtemps à part ses romans que
j'écrivais à plusieurs une personne
n'avait le droit de poser les yeux sur
ce que je faisais de fanny mes parents
ni mes soeurs ni mes amis et à un moment
donné je suis arrivé à la fin de mes
études d'économie gestion et j'ai connu
une petite période de recherche d'emploi
ouais et je me suis dit c'est le moment
de te lancer dans un vrai projet parce
que jusqu'à maintenant c'était des
débuts de romans tous finalement
abandonné au bout de cinquante pages 60
et là je me suis dit nantes a du temps
c'est le moment de lancer à fond et donc
c'est là qu'est né je revenais des
autres qui est sorti en troisième métier
t'aimons très premier roman pas d'accord
quand j'ai fini par boucler pour la
première fois de ma vie un roman et de
cas je me suis dit il faut le faire lire
cette fois ça suffit donc la première à
étapes ça a été de le faire dire à mes
proches mon cercle très très proche
familiale et familiales amicales et puis
et puis là je me suis dit bon maintenant
il faut à élargir un petit peu donc
j'avais choisi de le déposer sur la
plateforme amazon mais qui n'était pas
du tout adaptée à sa en réalité il s'est
rien passé du tout pendant des années
mais jamais non j'ai dû le déposer en
2000 celle je revenais des autres vins
puis les douleurs fantômes sa suite en
2016 également et il se passait plus
rien jusqu'à ce que je reprenne
l'écriture d'un troisième roman tout le
bleu du ciel qu'est sorti en premier qui
est sorti en premier parce que à ce
moment là j'ai décidé d'abandonner
l'idée d' amazon et j'ai entendu parler
d'une autre plateforme bon ben c'est
raymond best-seller points comme
vraiment dédié à les ailes à l'écriture
à la littérature d'accord et alors là et
alors là en quelques semaines tout s'est
accéléré je l' ai déposé fin janvier
2018 ouais et 2 avril je crois je
renvoyais un contrat d'édition signé
vers vers une maison d'édition
parisienne donc en à peine deux mois
tous et tout s'est accéléré les cloches
et des commentaires à donner sur des
bonnes notes
il a grimpé dans le classement il a
obtenu la petite pastille coup de coeur
et puis tout s'est enchaîné c'était le
bon moment oui le grand outil est alors
juste pour savoir en ce moment les
éditeurs attendent des succès sur
internet sur ce genre de plateforme ou
pas pas forcément ça dépend vraiment des
zi par une nouvelle façon de faire alors
pour certaines maisons d'édition oui
mais par exemple albin michel cicchitto
jardin voilà ils sont encore beaucoup
dans le courrier à les inscrire sur
prussienne à l'ancienne et ils essayent
de justement de devenir surveillée de
chômage plus petits éditeurs peut-être
sont plus à l'affût parce qu'ils
reçoivent moins de manuscrits comme déjà
inconnue donc ils sont plus à l'affût de
petites pépites qui serait ré sur
internet d'accord mais ça devient une
nouvelle façon de recruter en tout cas
vous trouver des talents wake cefrio
musiciens d'ailleurs oui d'accord et
alors du coup vous avez consacré ce
qu'il faut dire surtout c'est que le
palmarès du figaro c'est 2021 oui c'est
ça voilà vous classe 8e dans les
meilleures ventes de romans à savoir
deux cent seize mille ouvrages vendus
gdb de 600 milles 6 jeudi peu avant ça
c'est un 15 u 614 1000 jeux phares
historiques vérité
jdd les infos away 600000 pluie s'est
arrêtée à plus de 6 600 milles tout
exemplaire confondues sur 2021 d'accord
bon bah voilà qui éclaire très bien
excuser moi il n'y a pas de soucis voilà
et à l'eau du coup si vous venez un tout
petit peu une ville où même beaucoup
pourquoi pas les douleurs fantômes donc
c'est le dernier c'est la suite de
gervais les autres voilà et on retrouve
la même bande d'amis ça veut dire quoi
les douleurs fantômes alors les douleurs
fantômes j'ai choisi de jouer sur la
symbolique et les douleurs fantômes d'un
point de vue médical ce sont des
douleurs que peut ressentir une personne
dont un des membres a été amputé ou même
des personnes atteintes de paraplégie
elles vont avoir des douleurs à un
membre bien qu'ils aient plus aucune
connexions nerveuses plus aucune logique
et en fait c'est j'ai décidé de jouer
sur ce terme puisque c'est le membre
absent qui fait souffrir c'est le
l'absence qui fait souffrir et dans les
douleurs fantômes on parle beaucoup
d'absents d'être d'être aimé qui sont
absents et qu'ils nous font souffrir et
dont la présence est peut-être plus
forte que celle des présents justement
d'accord alors juste pour revenir à je
revenais des autres ça s'est un peu
c'est la suite on peut le lire quand
même on peut lire sans avoir à le
premier on peut le lire indépendamment
parce que c'est une toute autre histoire
c'est une bande d'amis qui se retrouvent
après s'être perdue donc on peut
attaquer dia comme sa part à ces
retrouvailles après c'est mieux d'avoir
compris tout ce qui s'était passé tout
ce qui s'était joué avant d'accord il y
aura une suite à celui-là non c'est pas
bien les récits bay d'accord alors on me
dit quand j'ai lu en préparant les
missions que vous aviez déjà un roman
terminé la doublure de même
le japon change à une vitesse non depuis
hier ça y est il est terminé le deuxième
d'accord réalité j'ai pas forcément
parler j'en avais de terminer j'ai
beaucoup plus parlé de la doublure
pasqua est celui qui sort au go à
l'automne cette année c'est ça et je me
suis pas étaler sur le suivant vous êtes
prêt à être allés voilà moi je sais
c'est une info en exclusivité il
est la doublure ça sauve aussi chez
albin michel voilà on va sauter voilà
ils sont des livres indépendant donc
complètement alors il a je vais m'amuser
à aller dans un autre genre à surprendre
mon lecteur fait vraiment on va vers
alors dans mes précédents romans on est
beaucoup sur la résilience la
reconstruction la lumière et l'espoir
est là je vais creuser mais toujours
dans la psychologie les schémas
relationnel mais dans le très sombre
tout ce qu'il ya de plus toxique ce
qu'il ya de plus malsain ah ouais
d'accord ouais on va complètement
changer mais ce sera toujours ma plume
c'est toujours moi mes personnages et ma
façon de les amener ça sera toujours à
la montagne non du tout choquent
découvert ah ouais parce que vos romans
sont souvent donc des vraies en pleine
nature les pyrénées lovenox c'est la
nature qui vous inspire si vous aimez
oui et puis elle apporte beaucoup à mes
romans elle est presque un personnage à
part entière est d'accord
ça se voulait disons que mes personnages
étaient tous un petit peu cabossés par
la vie venait de vivre des drames et le
fait de les mettre dans un cadre
grandiose naturel me permettait de les
mettre à distance par rapport à leurs
problèmes voilà face à une montagne on
est minuscule ça nous remet un petit peu
les pieds sur terre d'accord je
comprends et alors j'ai lu j'espère que
c'est vrai que vous étiez intéressé par
des formations que voulait suiviez même
de sophrologie naturopathie et 3ème
sophrologie nature métro ma thérapie oui
alors je me suis lancé oui je m'y étais
lancé très très sérieusement et je vous
avoue que depuis qui a toute cette
effervescence autour de mes romans j'ai
un petit peu voilà j'ai un petit peu de
nice a donc souhaité h comprends mais
c'est toujours là ça m'intéresse
toujours ce qu'on fait c'est l'humain je
me disais ce que voulait faire ça pour
commencer un peu côté solitaire de
l'écriture l'écriture ou alors pour
nourrir vos romans avec d'autres avec de
la matière à nourrir sa plaidoirie de me
nourrir aussi ouais bon pour l'instant
je n'ai rien à mon avis parce que je
suis la prise par le côté promotion
assez tard et elle va vous raconter
que vous avez été très très surprise la
première fois que vous avez fait un
salon littéraire vous voyez une file
d'attenté lacan témoin alors j'avais
démarré les salons à l'époque où tout
bleu du ciel étaient sortis en grand
format donc avant le coville et mais
j'étais une inconnue il venait de sortir
personne ne venait me voir à mon stand
c'était très très long il fallait passer
le temps total dure bas c'est dur mais
en même temps c'est logique qu'un jeu et
puis je suis pas une commerciale je suis
pas une vendeuse donc je vais pas la
gérer les gens
mal à l'aise et donc il ya eu les divers
confinement est là la reprise des salons
pour de vrai et là effectivement il
s'était passé quelque chose pendant le
confinement tout le bleu du ciel était
sorti en poche les dents demain était
sorti et j'avais un vrai public
désormais que vous aider à trouver grâce
à ce qu'on filme en finance à le saluer
et vous ment plus est notre langue voilà
ont eu besoin de vous avez des thèmes
aussi qui courait 16 a peut-être
tout bleu du ciel c'est le voyage
beaucoup m'ont dit j'ai voyagé pendant
le confinement grâce à ce bouquin et
j'avais besoin de m'évader de voyager le
donc le voyage la nature dans tous mes
romans mes personnages se mettre sur
pause se coupent avec le rythme effréné
de la société d'accepter totalement en
phase et puis refaire le point pourquoi
pas changer de vie
complètement où beaucoup de gens ont eu
ces réflexions pendant le confinement
justement alarmiste extrêmement tombait
pile poil je pense moi là mais écoutez
mélissa da costa un grand bravo pour ce
dernier lit pour votre carrière et puis
à très bientôt pour le prochain livre la
double et puis ce noyau on sera prêt
avec merci en tout cas d'être venu sur
le plateau mais assez habite mélissa
[Musique]